a father is outraged after his daughter
was bill for a guardrail that he says
contributed to her death
honors died in a car crash last November
in Tennessee months later a bill came
charging her for replacing the guardrail
and his father believed she would still
be alive if the x-lite guardrail stopper
had not sliced through her car he is
calling on the state to remove all
x-lite guardrail in pieces
they're about 1,000 in Tennessee they're
linked to at least four deaths Kris Van
Cleave is outside Washington DC to share
how guardrail shouldn't help in a wreck
Chris good morning good morning well
guardrail is designed to absorb some of
the impact in a crash particularly up
here at the terminal it's designed to
crumple backwards like this one did and
that can make a crash less severe that's
if the guardrail works as intended they
killed her then they built her nearly
four months after Steve Eimer 17 year
old daughter Hannah
died in a car crash Tennessee sent a
nearly three thousand dollar bill for
repairs to the guardrail she collided
with it is one of the most emotionally
tone-deaf acts that I think I have ever
witnessed it wasn't made out to me it
was made out to Hannah I was furious
last November Hannah's car left
Interstate 75 as she corrected she
collided with the end of an ex white
guardrail stopper killing her instantly
when it intruded into her Volvo sedans
driver's door striking her in the chest
and head I don't understand how you can
leave a dangerous product on the road
after you've already acknowledged it
that's Russian roulette the state of
Tennessee chose to play Russian roulette
with people's lives and my daughter is
dead just days before Hannah's crash the
Tennessee Department of Transportation
stopped installing that type of guard
rail terminals citing safety and
performance concerns and is now
replacing them on roads with speed
limits over 45 miles an hour we have
seen some crashes on the state highway
system
and how these products are reacting to
some of these particularly the high
speed type crashes palled eggs from the
Tennessee Department of Transportation
admits sending the bill was a horrible
mistake the department really apologizes
for that in recent years there has been
mounting concern about the performance
of some guardrails Shawn Kane is a
vehicle safety expert and president of
safety research and strategies when they
work they work very well what we've seen
over time though is is a variety of
different changes have made them less
safe now in a statement the maker of
that guardrail tells CBS this morning it
had successfully passed crash and safety
tests in accordance with federal
standards adding it is widely recognized
that there are impact conditions that
exceed the performance expectations of
all safety equipment gale boy Chris
thank you beautiful girl Hannah was and
you really feel for her dad I think he
described it best when he said he mostly
tone-deaf yeah really really glad that
he's speaking out who needs to be a
better way to resolve that a great